[Music]
in ready to rumble news submitted by
long-lost fan hey welcome back
glad we found you YouTube stars bringing
1.6 million viewers and a head-to-head
boxing match wait to YouTube it's just
the chaos iana i watch this [ __ ] what yo
you don't fight yo check this [ __ ] out I
will say this though you know why I love
[ __ ] UK youtubers why cuz they
actually box it out when they don't like
each other
that's dog this ksi guy first of all not
a big fan of him because he used Guk as
a racial slur so [ __ ] that guy but I
will say though he call out this other
dude he didn't like and actually a legit
boxing man what kind of tuber is he I
don't know a rapper some [ __ ] I've never
seen their video like five four things
oh okay si I only know because he called
me out as being his youtube crush in
like 2012 and like a bunch of his people
came over to my channel like I checked
out like what his channel wasn't it's
like it's like five he like just fight
for stuff and then now he's doing like
the YouTube challenges but he's just
he's very loud what's 535 FIFA no not
soccer football which makes more sense
is a rapper slash comedian and actor and
let's not say after he was in late in
America that movie that came out with
all those youtubers like yeah so let's
not say I watched the whole fight I
think it lasted about 15 or 20 minutes
oh yeah they went like three or four
rounds oh so who was the person he
fought it's this white youtuber he
fought Joe Weller he's 21 year old
youtuber he's best known for his
commentary playing Fifa
like a FICO score he also does a comedy
sketches and he also does like haunted
places no way so that's Joe Weller right
and so ksi he's 24 years old and like I
said rapper comedian so okay it's not a
20
for yeah everybody's hello young yes I
have seventeen point nine million
subscribers jo Jo Weller has four point
million four point seven million that's
a lot too though yeah so these are the
guys so they started their beef on
Twitter and and so like they announced
back in August that they would go
head-to-head in a boxing that they
really have beef though or is it like
legit they don't like each other
no they legit don't like each other oh
really watch the boxing match in a
second so then patience young Barton
because I know everybody else is like I
want to watch boxing match okay so I'm
just speaking for the fans all right
here's a buck you met yeah I could tell
from here that's the job of GG is why
all the ref is still wanting to know
each other that's amazing the camera
[Music]
I don't know why he ended that fight
there he was defending himself
intelligently sure if you're getting
hooked in the face like seven times it's
done hope so he didn't get knocked out
no no no he stopped it but then right
before that he got hit and then you know
they put him to his corner and as soon
as he came back he got railed on again
so I think done
he just stopped it there but he had his
hands up though it wasn't like he wasn't
defending himself that's tough I just
wanted him to get not one of them to get
knocked out
like that's cool man see I wish American
youtubers could do that [ __ ] well
because American YouTube about the
American fans with watch the shoes I
want to [ __ ] me depends on youtubers
demographics because I don't want them
to do a boxing match I want them to a
full-on enemy yeah with the [ __ ]
one-inch gloves just smashing you turn
the [ __ ] face that'd be amazing as if
they both do FIFA commentary then their
fans are like sports fans like so
they're watching but if we had like
American YouTube so if you had like Joey
Graceffa like David so versus Peter Chao
but even with the headgear though
there's a video of the Joe guy he hasn't
like he has like a black eye and yes
like hoes like damn dude you got I had
to wear headgear because they're not
professional boxers they don't have like
the boxing license and they were saying
that the viewers peaked at 1.6 million
which makes it the foxy boxing
largest live audience Wow a fight back
in April last year so this has been like
the most viewed and and UK boxing or
international boxing national fanuc
we're talking about this because
remember when the whole Logan Paul thing
was going on I was like I challenged him
to a MMA duel so then someone sent me
this they're like Oh someone took your
idea and I'm like what case I ended up
challenging Logan Paul and Jake Paul
yeah
a ring like ass he was like you know
she'd be handed up yeah you ready so my
face
what saw what happen will happen how can
we give her a face because I already
like this kid she went way you got to
hear this just I don't know anything
about oh well not about the kid but the
fact that like he called the pulls out
and then so Jake Paul ended up putting
this who is psi and why are people
tweeting me about him that is the
sorriest joke I've ever in hands-on of
creating a whole video of like being
comedian Jake Paul does not make you
laugh I guess not
what's wrong with me I'm sorry yeah so
then he ended up tweeting this out is
the photo of his dad he says after
calling me and my brother Logan Paul out
for no reason and saying you'd fight any
person with the last name of Paul be a
man of your word represent represent
England and fight my 55 year old dad is
so funny cuz he's still hiding behind
his parents and he says Logan and I will
also pay you 50 K bet you won't do it
okay he's like I bet you won't fight my
dad broke [ __ ] that's gotta be the
biggest [ __ ] move Earth Day cuz sons
are supposed to fight the dad fights
don't throw you don't throw your [ __ ]
dad in front of you daddy protect me
daddy put your dad he's like close to
retirement bro then can't side tweeted
this out he goes boy I would drop you
quicker than dizzy ah
Oh Jake follows him on Twitter so he
knows who Kaos is he also pointed out in
a video case I played out in a video
that like they they texted each other
because they went to some event together
and then he kept sending him photos of
random black people saying like is this
you or I think I see you he was just
like racist jokes or whatever but
typical as a white boy guys psi joke was
like the most cringe-worthy job he was
calling like KFC and like all of these
well it's so cringy dude Ben yeah and
then KFC's kind of funny yeah okay you
like my chicken oh my god but if you
watch the whole fight though I give it
to him cuz I um at first I didn't know I
thought they were like amateur boxers
that's how good it was like oh [ __ ] look
like they know what they're doing yeah
they got training they probably trained
yeah I love that that's like a really
cool way to just resolve your [ __ ] and
then like it's cool and then it's over
like the bits of beef over like are they
gay yeah so a joe ended up posting a
video after the fight he was just
congratulating cases like you earned it
so dope yeah that's how they used to
squash beef yeah can't we do that these
days you can they're bringing it back
during the chivalrous days yeah but I
mean like now now like just didn't you
know they have to bring it back right
like how come it can't be done anymore
especially in California who are two
youtubers that you want to see [ __ ]
do any of them any of them alright
literally ale
give me to them and I'm like that's an
justify I think I want to see the Paul
brothers Logan and Jake just start
jabbing they went in no but if they went
a hundred percent it will be so
satisfying because one of them has to
lose and I want to see even oh my I want
to see my one of my favorite youtubers
Joel go fight Logan Paul okay well
stepping on a cockroach like 50 he would
destroy him yeah he'd destroy all the
other youtubers are you David
I don't know like it's it's hard because
I I don't want I want somebody who could
fight to fight somebody who could really
fight yeah you know I don't watch a
street fight through some world star
shoot that's dope I love watching five
videos on YouTube you know what happened
to the good old days of YouTube when it
was dog cat videos and bikes yeah I
still watch that [ __ ] me too no no it's
funny too because in a Jake was calling
ksi like oh he's irrelevant like who is
this guy he has way more subscribers one
point million people [ __ ] tuned into
the fight yeah seventeen million sold
out the venue which was like eight
thousand people eight thousand that's
amazing it's just that's the new discs
they go you're irrelevant it's like I
guess doesn't tell me that all right
didn't he even put them in the title of
his video and like calling him and then
people are pointing that out on the
comments too like oh he's so irrelevant
but you put his name in the title yeah
yeah it's kind of funny so cool though
it's so cool that they got to punch each
other's faces in those guys they've
earned my respect they can say as many
Asian jokes as they want now they've
earned
you can't he doesn't mean that you make
fun of me as much as you want cuz you've
earned my respect cuz you're actually
fought I like you okay I want it I want
to see Hank green from from the crash
course I want to see him by Bill Nye the
Science Guy was gonna die I want to see
I want to see Ryan Higa with joy right
here well [ __ ] David Toria Ryan knows
judo some tricky tricks DJ in black belt
in judo and he was a state champion
wrestler so Ryan Higa PI [ __ ] up 80% of
YouTube okay well let's not put David
Cho in there okay okay okay that'll be a
massacre alright let's go with jenna
Marbles and she should like anaconda do
a video where she's like this hey guys
so this is a bag it'll get [ __ ] 2
million views she still kills it but
she's still funny though like she just
doesn't give a [ __ ] like she's like I'm
doing videos for me now like she just
does like things that she's interested
I never stuff pop up so I didn't know
like if she was it only pops up if you
watch them like if you start watching
people yeah the algorithm just screws us
all over yeah cuz now everything is just
like funneled into like just the same
thing yeah it only shows your audience
it's like you title like a tag on all
the videos like it'll show than those
particular videos I'm not you - oh I
want to see a - on to the fine brothers
and then the vlog brothers yeah it'll be
a two-on-two wrestling match you guys be
done if someone called you guys out
depending on who it is no because some
people will do it come on Barney man
hello child's pose like a Bart was like
20 hey would it be really fun of me and
David didn't MMA that's absolutely not
doing that [ __ ] today it was terrifying
it depends if they if they want to
because they like me or if they want to
because they just wanted to take my
thing I will I will duel out with Bart
if I get gloves with shards of glass in
it and then I also have a helmet with
spikes he loves a lot of pain though so
the more pain you inflict a thumbs up
gets my fists well I'm done you love
this so much that he grabs a point he
points his butt at you and goes whip me
come out make them high any luck
gonna have to plug in blow drys like
this
[Music]
[Music]